les savoyards ont leurs fromages les
basques le jambon les normands le cidre
mais y at il des spécialités locales à
saint quentin en yvelines
nous avons mené une véritable enquête de
terrain ce week end au marché des
terroirs de voisins-le-bretonneux jamais
réussi à trouver une spécialité du coin
d'ici à non j'ai pas vu s'il y en a je
n'ai pas vu vous savez s'il ya des
spécialités du pont peut-être mais je
les connais pas bon c'était mal parti et
puis on a trouvé robert mon produit
phare fait la bière blanche à la pomme
c'est à dire c'est la guillaume tell
c'est une bière dans laquelle on ajoute
du jus de pomme
sauf que voilà ce sont mes marques ce
sont mes produits
mais je les fais produire en fait donc
je ne produis pas directement et la
bière blanche la pomme je la fais
produire en belgique
et puis soudain au détour d'une
conversation tout après on a des
produits d'île de france on représente
la brasserie walsall s située dans la
vallée de chevreuse et également la
bière bon roi qu'une brasserie située
également sur la vallée de chevreuse
maintenant vous êtes avertis oui saint
quentin en yvelines et ses alentours ont
aussi leurs propres produits du terroir